how jennifer lopez surprised ben affleck
details about benifer's tribute to their
kids and stunning never before seen
photos somebody's getting married
yeah the latest on the jlo newsletter
has it all at least if we're talking ben
and jen's wedding i'm ready i'm excited
about it first up jen reveals singer
mark cohn performed during their
ceremony
and for good reason according to jlo the
couple fell in love with mark song true
companion when they were first together
over 20 years ago i got my heart set on
our wedding day
i've got this vision of a girl in white
j lo writes though ben didn't know i
asked mark to surprise him by singing it
at our wedding and he was lovely and
generous to come i never imagined the
true companion that somebody plays it at
their wedding to know that you've had
any effect with what you do on somebody
is wonderful jlo says ben was shocked to
see mark playing their special song
i'm asking you to be my true companion
she recalls as the eldest of our
children finished her walk mark began
true companion a song we first listened
to together what seemed both like
yesterday and forever ago yeah the
couple's five kids got a spotlight
moment of their own when mark sang
another meaningful song the things we've
handed down
[Music]
the things we've handed down
jen describes the track like this a song
about the wonderful mystery of children
reflecting on the day she says some old
wounds were healed that day and the
weight of the past finally lifted off of
our shoulders it is honestly one of the
like 10 sweetest most precious moments
i've ever witnessed in my life yeah it
was absolutely beautiful uh you know
she's got impeccable taste so the whole
wedding looks fantastic yeah no
arguments here jlo also shares pics from
across the three-day wedding weekend
some highlights the pop icons luke for
the rehearsal dinner the reception
sparkling from top to bottom and just
look at this spread at the next day
barbecue
beautifully appointed flawless
jlo explains the vibes were down home
rustic country chic and i wanted each
day to have its own personality but fit
the setting we were in for the weekend
we're super happy
days later jen reflects on the long road
to their special day we find ourselves
in that long desired time of life having
gratitude for all that life has shown us
even its trials and tribulations that
night really was heaven
[Music]
you